over the last two weeks coronavirus
hospitalizations have trended upward in
at least 14 states including Texas where
there's concern the spread is
accelerating the Raya Villarreal has
more from Dallas we're concerned with
the trajectory we see dr. boom is
president of Houston Methodist hospitals
he says the number of Kovac patients
hospitalized in that city has tripled
since Memorial Day if we don't all work
together to bring this curve back down
yes we're going to have a challenging
situation and as the average rate of
positive tests continues to rise
governor Greg Abbott is urging Texans to
stay home because the spread is so
rampant right now there's never a reason
for you to have to leave your home taxes
is one of 26 states reporting an
increase in average daily coronavirus
cases compared to two weeks ago cases in
Oklahoma are up 245 percent over that
same period and 168 percent in Florida
this is not about more testing this is
about more spread of the virus dr. Tom
Frieden is the former director of the
Centers for Disease Control those
increases are from spread that happened
a week or two or three ago so the
increase is probably going to continue
for a few more weeks some business
owners are making those changes on their
own you know you're gonna lose money I
might lose business
Michael Knapp owns the cottonmouth Club
in Houston as bars become hotspots in
his state he closed his bar again on
what he calls an obligation to the
community I don't know how many people
have to get sick and die so I can stay
in business and now this could affect
travel we understand as cases continue
to rise here in the US there is a
consideration by other countries are
worried about American tourists coming
in there is a new report that says the
European Union is now considering a ban
on American tourists coming in as they
begin to reopen their borders Tony Boyer
thank you very much